pepper or we have opted doodie in the
hate test yeah you don't even know
what's coming for you
[Music]
hi I'm Farah and I have a small little
dog named gizmo hi I'm Lara and I have a
5 pound little rat named pepper and we
decided to get our dogs DNA tested
obviously we're both obsessed with our
dogs and we take them hiking together a
lot like their friends so honestly when
she did it she was like I know Lara will
want to do this - and of course I did
prior to the testing I thought I knew
what pepper was like she looks hard
Yorkie and part Maltese so like it
wasn't too much of a mystery and I knew
what gizmo was a little bit before the
test because the family whose dogs gave
birth to gizmo said that their dogs were
shih tzu and the father I think was full
Chihuahua a little kit I have to swap
her this little thing honestly like
every time I try and brush her teeth she
freaks out so it should be a good
experience so for all we'll see how it
goes the swabbing process for me
she had the healthy and whole pepper
downs pepper doesn't like anything going
near her mouth you should see when I try
and give her her flea medication we're
gonna try this you ready no
[Music]
but you did it on your own I did I see
he's not actually gonna let me stick it
in his mouth but then once I I kind of
had to like calm him down and then
slowly like introduce the swab Dilek his
mouth and then just sort of like insert
it into his gums very very gently and
then once he got used to it he just like
let me do it but are you glad it's over
yeah thank you
pepper didn't let us do it but she's
hollering yeah that's a very good word
[Music]
you know see I'm honestly a little
nervous to see the health stuff for
peppers DNA test because I'm emotionally
attached to pepper in a way that I never
thought was possible and in a way that
scares the [ __ ] outta me they have both
been through a lot in our lives and our
dogs just have been there through a lot
of that both the good and the bad and so
obviously we want our dogs to be healthy
and happy I'm very scared at the
possibility of it telling me something
that could mean less time with her I've
worried about her passing away since
like the day but I met her I think
what's making me nervous about doing
this test is because I've been through a
few traumatic situations with gizmo
already I figured out he's allergic to
bees like deathly allergic and I've had
to like rush him to the vet twice on the
brink of death and Oh
yeah hello did she just eat some bread
smells like dog food pepper came into my
life during a time when it was really
dark and she's always there for me on my
darkest days she never leaves my side so
to think about the possibility of her
being sick or being in pain and the
rolls kind of being reversed like it
makes me so sad so I'm very nervous for
that these moms just you know my son and
I care about him so much and we've been
through a lot together he was literally
the only living thing in my apartment
with me when I found out my dad had
passed and was sort of my first sense of
comfort that I had through that I think
I'm just worried for what will be
revealed in the health portion of it
just because he's just so important to
me and I don't want to lose him it's my
little bud
my little guy I don't know I guess we'll
see what happens
[Music]
so gizmos breed results came in from
embarked and we know that this guy is
37% Chihuahua 27% jitsu 15% Chinese
Crested 12% Pomeranian and then 7%
Pekinese the home he has Pommery
yep Wow
Deniz how him how do you feel about that
I did he just kind of looked at me yeah
I was like no we just feel fine I was
surprised
by the results like I said I thought
pepper was like straight first of all I
don't even know if you can be 50/50
anything like that's what I've learned
it doesn't make sense not how things
work
I thought pepper was straight
fifty-fifty like Maltese Yorkie but
according to this she's 50% Yorkshire
Terrier 29.7% Maltese 11.9% Pekinese and
8.4 % cocker spaniel Wow dudes were both
a little bit older than he is
yeah oh yeah I was a little bit
surprised as well because again I
thought it was gonna be like 5050 but
yeah I think that the lower percents
were probably what was the most
surprising so from the very beginning I
was kind of scared about the health
results that I was gonna get back from
gizmo and I had a minor freakout earlier
when his health results came in because
he's at risk for only one thing he has
one gene mutation for something called
primary lens luxation I kind of kept on
reading and researching just to kind of
understand what it meant
luckily embark gives you access to
veterinarians that you can talk to but
they also give you a lot of information
on like what it is primary lens luxation
is a disorder where at the outside of
the lens like tongues detached
essentially so dismal only has one copy
of the mutation and to my knowledge one
copy of this mutation is better than
having two copies which you're at a
higher risk for developing this PLL so
because that's something I learned
through this DNA
staying I'm trying not to freak out
about it but it's something that I can
the next time I go to the bed let them
know that these were the results and
like what would our next steps be or
what I can look out for and things like
that pepper didn't have any surprise
health scare switch I was actually
really surprised about because like in
my mind I was convinced that it was
gonna tell me that like she was dying so
I was just like super freaked out but
they test for X amount of things and she
came back negative all the things that
they look for that doesn't mean that
she's like a perfect dog and that's what
I have to keep her mind it well she is
perfect and doesn't mean she has perfect
health which is what I have to keep
reminding myself and like there are
other things that can come up and
obviously she's something to go to the
vet but it it gave me like a little bit
of a sense of peace because I was like
my little baby is healthy and happy and
I'm gonna be okay so I'm sort of glad
for embark just for giving me this
knowledge versus not having the
knowledge and not being able to know
what to look out for I think the overall
process was like super easy and chill
and I would totally do it again I'm
happy with the way that it turned out
obviously because pepper like came back
negative for most things and also like
now I know more about our family if
you're curious and you have disposable
income and you love your dog like do it
yeah if you have a breed of dog that is
predisposed to some type of like
hereditary illness or disease it's worth
doing just so you can be prepared guess
not even just mentally but financially
too and just give you the peace of mind
because you know unfortunately things
happen and I guess it's better if you're
prepared I'm glad I did it I'm glad I
know gizmo a little bit more thank you
guys for listening to us talk about our
obsession with our dogs and if there's
anything else you want to know
you went way more in depth in the
article which you can check out in the
description of this video well that was
great
[Music]